moving on and North Korean State media
says that Kim Jong-un is on a train to
Russia to meet with Vladimir Putin U.S
Diplomat said last week that the north
is ready to supply ammunition to the
Russians for their war in Ukraine well
let's get more now with our
correspondent Florence Louis she's in
Seoul following this for us uh float
scenes that Kim has left Pyongyang do we
know exactly where he's headed there's
obviously been huge speculation that
he's on his way to meet Putin
well there's no official confirmation
well from the South Korean side but
South Korean media are quoting unnamed
sources from the South Korean government
here that this train is headed for the
border with Russia and likely to
Vladivostok now Vladivostok is about a
thousand kilometers from Pyongyang an
honored bullet train this distance would
be covered in just over three hours but
with North Korea's archaic Railway
system this could be a journey of 20
hours possibly even more now Vladivostok
has been speculated could be the venue
for this meeting that's because Putin is
scheduled to deliver a speech at the
Eastern economic Forum on Tuesday
Vladimir stock is also the city where
the two leaders Kim and Putin met in
2019 this was Kim's first visit to
Russia after becoming leader of North
Korea now back then when the two leaders
met in 2019
um there was this whole idea of
projecting an image of friendship this
was after North Korean talks with the
U.S on nuclear disarmament had stalled
now any potential meeting between these
two leaders is also intended to send a
signal a message if you will but this
time the message more specifically for
the U.S and its allies
I need to say you know if you can supply
your allies Ukraine for example with
weapons if you can intensify military
drills with Partners South Korea and
Japan well then we Russia and North
Korea can do the same and it also comes
amid reports that these two leaders are
potentially considering an arms deal
take a look at this report
this would be no North Korean leader Kim
jong-un's first trip abroad since the
covet pandemic he's likely headed to
Russia's Far East close to the North
Korean border news of his possible visit
has reached residents in Vladivostok
where Kim met Russian President Vladimir
Putin in 2019.
both countries show tease to the whole
world and can stand for themselves so
there's something in common
Putin is in vlado stock to attend the
Eastern economic Forum an event designed
to promote foreign investment in
Russia's Far East
when the two leaders met four years ago
Putin had offered to break the deadlock
after North Korea's talks with the U.S
on nuclear disarmament failed
U.S officials believe a meeting this
time may include discussion of an arms
deal if North Korea sells weapons to
Moscow this is going to be a problem for
the United States as well as for Europe
because this would essentially try to be
an effort by Moscow to balance some of
the advantages that Ukraine has in terms
of getting material you know artillery
Rockets North Korea is banned from
exporting Weapons Under U.N security
Council resolution there are also
concerns North Korea may receive from
the Russians sophisticated technology
that could help it Advance its nuclear
weapons program Russia and North Korea
have drawn closer in recent months in
July Sergey shoigu visited Pyongyang the
first Russian defense minister to do so
since the fall of the Soviet Union
Russia is also discussing holding joint
military drills with North Korea
analysts say the Kim Putin meeting could
be intended to send a message to the U.S
and its allies with a bit of diplomacy
North Korea can be used as a tool to
influence behavior of the United States
South Korea and some other place largely
in regard to the Ukrainian conflict
for North Korea a potential arms deal
with Russia would also make sense
economically heavy flooding has worsened
the impoverished country's food supply
two countries led by authoritarian
rulers and under Western sanctions may
seem like natural allies but closer ties
between Russia and North Korea may also
serve to widen the divide in the
International Community much like during
the Cold War era Florence Louis Al
Jazeera Seoul
well let's now get the view from Russia
and speak to Yulia chapovalova for us in
Moscow Yulia as we were hearing there
there's been plenty of talk of this
meeting in Vladivostok on the sidelines
of the economic Forum that Putin is
speaking at what are you hearing from
Moscow
well for quite a long while Moscow
referred to State Tides Lipton didn't
comment on the possible visit of Kim
Jong-un although many admitted that all
the talks and rumors were not so
groundless so a president Kim expected
is expected in the Far East and the
coming days according to the Russian
media and right now there is no official
information regarding his departure from
the Russian side as we understand the
local news outlets are cautiously citing
South Korean sources by the way there
were some witness reports recently
alleging that some preparations at one
of La Diva stock train stations were
underway but as we know the city is
hosting the Eastern economic Forum right
now where President Putin is expected to
speak tomorrow on Tuesday September the
12th and there is a lot of activity in
the diva stock of course right now
anywhere as hundreds of thousands of
people arriving and departing the city
and the meeting with Kim Jong-un is
allegedly going to take place on
Wednesday the 13 so it will take came
some time to get to vladiva stock on his
armored train and officially both
presidents won't meet during the Forum
but straight after it but of course
we're waiting for official confirmation
Yulia if an arms deal is indeed in the
works what does Russia want and what
might it be prepared to give in return
so as we understand as many officials
well not officials rather but analysts
say uh Pyongyang can offer a munition
and multiple launch rocket systems and
short-range ballistic missiles and in
return Russia can offer grain oil our
part of its technology or paying hard
currency as unless here note this may be
agreed upon with China as well because
North Korea will act strictly according
to agreements with China that's what
people here say moreover is believed
that Korea can transfer Chinese weapons
because Korea has some Chinese weapons
or it it will it can replace its own
weapons with the Chinese ones for
example give the Russians its own
weapons produced over several decades
and replenish the reserves with the
Chinese ones and it is important also
for Vladimir Putin to demonstrate the
nation that Russia is not an
international isolation and
international contact is important for
Putin and for Russia but this is a very
you know strange context and the poor
deal in in the sense that the Russians
understand that North Korea is a very
slow developing country and that Russia
by interacting with North Korea puts
itself on the same level with it and the
more the Kremlin publicizes this topic
the more people will realize that
International level rationale finds
itself at well we'll continue watching
that situation very closely there indeed
Julia chapovalova there for us in Moscow
thank you Julia